okay so we're on to the final panel
which is on the future of creativity and
for this I'd like to ask our five Nobel
laureates to come on stage please
Michael Randi in the middle ear Vardhan
my Britt we don't know we were
discussing earlier whether it's good to
seat the husband-and-wife team together
or separated we didn't know so we just
went through together so I think
everybody knows everybody but just in
case car woman Michael Levitt Randy
Schekman edvard moser my Britt Moser
since we had this critical mass of Nobel
laureates present we thought it would be
good to explore the theme of creativity
just raised in the last panel especially
Biola for and we might start by asking
what we mean by creativity so Randy what
do you think of when you think of
creativity I guess when I but I think of
creativity it's the the ability or the
chance to put two or more seemingly
disparate observations or ideas together
in in an unexpected combination to yield
some novel insight that you couldn't
have imagined and I'm reminded of this
by the wonderful book by Francois Jacoby
called the statue within in which he
described the two kinds of science one
was daytime science and the other was
nighttime science daytime science was to
him the usual observations and ideas
that come together that are logical
nighttime science on the other hand was
this rare combination of things that
could not be anticipated very nice
Michael
you know the office definitions are that
you find something that was unexpected
is useful but I would say it's the aha
moment that you get while you're having
it so it's not what you think
vibrant creativity so of course I agree
with these people but I think going back
to science where I like to be then you
become creative if you have the ability
to listen to other people that have
different views from yourself but throw
don't throw the baby out with water so
you have to keep something for yourself
and then select what is good and what is
not so good from what other people try
to tell you and then you should be able
to see the pattern that is coming in
front of your eyes but you can talk
about the same thing in music we come
from Toronto which is the town for jazz
and jazz is to put different pieces of
music together that wasn't combined
before but you can't do that if you
haven't played beautiful music so you
need something there and then as you say
combine it in new ways I think we should
get everyone's comments on this so it's
not somewhat similar I think it's about
putting together pieces of information
that your brain has collected over long
times which haven't been seen together
before and using that to solve some
either solve the problem or just create
an insight so I think it's somewhat like
dreaming what this happens to I mean
random pieces of information occur
together sometimes that even leads to a
new insight yeah
tackle is benzene ringing yeah come it's
so naturally when I was thinking about
teaching and learning studying this not
quite a bit early I'm thinking about it
in it
and I think it's it's with it it always
really has to be within the context of
kind of an existing issue or question in
it so it's very much in scientific
creativity is very much residing in a
discipline and kind of all the things
you know about it but it's then coming
as other people said sort of recognizing
a different pattern or some new
information from somewhere else that's
relevant really just and what the real
test is it's things that turn out to be
useful but other people haven't seen yet
or recognized yet and just put them one
little plug that what we came to
recognize was the the educational system
really teaches anti creativity because
it's really about you know teachers are
giving students problems to solve and
the goal is to have an answer that looks
like what the teacher was looking for
and that's exactly not being creative
and so when we tied the experiments of
giving problems that didn't have answers
the teachers were looking for the
students actually perform much more
creatively on further task but as you
and others upon job that needs to be a
foundational base absolutely yes so 70%
of the audience or the audience
responders we gathered of positive about
the idea that we will be more creative
in 30 years that humans will be there
either think it's likely all extremely
likely do you think that's the case
adversity I think will be creative in a
different way you didn't have a box for
that apparently so I think it's not more
or less but we will interact much more
with computers and use in the
information that can pop up within
milliseconds of course that will make us
think and act in a different way but I
think it's not a more-or-less question
that's how nature works too because you
know not creativity that has a positive
value ER for us but but nature is filled
with mutations and that is how we get
variation and we get new species we get
new behavior so we need this
and of course for us to be creative then
it's more positive that we think that we
see things in a better way and we're
smarter
well one of the trends in the life
sciences and I think probably in all
science is the the need to collaborate
across lines people who bring different
technologies to bear on a problem and
that that will reinforce the creative
experience because you will have to deal
with other people of a very different
perspective and if it's a if it's a an
effective team effort then I think
they'll be there there will be some
creative tension that arises from that
collaboration yes it goes down to the
definition that you've been getting
before that creativity involves
interaction of several things the world
is becoming a much more interactive
place and people who were unimpaired can
now go online and often do some really
creative things so I think that the
creativity divided by the population is
going to increase enormously do you find
that in your own life technology makes
you more creative because as you get
older you know you're losing neurons all
the time and it's not clear that maybe
it makes you stay more or less the same
I guess there's one interesting thing
and that is as you get older but
normally in life it's much easier to do
something you know how to do they seduce
something new when you have no memory
there's no nothing at you everything's
about the same you know just heard you
say some things about people people who
are older scientists who say they're
doing the best work of their career
before you skating about well I'm a
little worried about that I've told my
friends that if I ever at this point for
the rest of my life say that I'm doing
the best work of my life and then it is
a sure sign of senility and delusion so
I feel that I did my best work when I
was 30 years old because I had no
preconceived notions about the field
I had no prejudices built up over
and I could do something that other
people thought was crazy and feel good
about it
what about being creative I still think
I'm creative I think advantage of
getting older is that you accumulate
more and more it is a random information
you get more and more exposed to
knowledge outside your own field
something that is quite often not the
case for young people when they start in
a difficult field so and so it's it in a
different way so I don't think I'm done
yet I just wanted to reflect also on
what is stopping creativity and that is
fear and you can get fear of course if
people tell you that you're stupid you
shouldn't think about these topics or
you shouldn't think along these lives
but also fear that you don't have the
methods or the techniques to address
your question and that has happened now
in your science that we have got all
these wonderful wonderful techniques so
that we are much tougher than when we
were young to address questions that we
couldn't try even to think of addressing
earlier for example with optogenetics or
all these new techniques that we can use
and then we are so creative I tend to
think I I don't think the biggest
barriers fear I think the biggest
barrier is habit so you just get deeper
deeper into that was as you get open so
you're not gonna be as creative I just
wanted to follow up on what Brandi said
like I did my best work when I was like
21 years old I knew nothing and what
really worries me today is that people
become independent
I know too much we're really on a 6-year
PhD and the six-year postdoc they are
too old and I really believe that
there's a something really wrong with
the system so I think when I talks about
creativity I think the world is gonna be
more creative I actually think that
science per dollar spent is gonna become
less creative I have exactly that worry
and it's because people are just too
long the whole system has become people
okay when you're older so for me right
now 64 is super young right and but you
know people have forgotten that there's
an absolute youngness 40 is not the new
20 20 is we're making a huge mistake we
sort of say well it's scientists are
complicated then you learn all these new
things and it's basically just a way to
have in a really good labor in your lab
doing things for you and it's a huge
mistake I think the system is really
rotten for this reason I think what well
so my generation the baby boomers
generation were lucky because when
people old philosophers that have taken
out of the system by the Great
Depression in the second world war
unfortunately people are young growing
up now still fast
so I share all of those concerns on the
other hand Margaret Cho say you can
teach people to be much more creative I
mean you know if you actually said about
you couldn't actively doing that and
probably at any age although we haven't
tested that in our field we don't have
this - at least not myself but I work in
a group and I depend on all this
beautiful young people in our lab and we
are facilitating creativity in our lab
by having an environment where you are
allowed to ask questions and you are
forced to ask questions and then it's a
brainstorming which creates creativity
and I find it so fascinating so when we
have meetings with our people I am so
happy and passion
makes creativity is there is there
almost a kind of conflict though between
the collaboration that Randy mentioned
for instance that you need Club the
meeting of idea is to be creative but
also the kind of being on your own and
fresh then sort of solo that you were
when you were doing your best work maybe
and you were Michael when you were doing
a work at 21 I mean there's almost is a
conflict between the need to collaborate
and the need to be an individual but
some problems now are so complicated
that they require different technologies
for for progress so you are forced I
think not in a bad way but forced to
reach out to collaborate with people who
have a technique that you can't easily
apply and I think that from that can
come some creative tension as long as
the - is that as the collaborators are
open and share everything and they're
willing to consider alternatives Michael
I think the key thing here is certainly
when I was a young scientist people
people people's PhD supervisor does not
expect the names to be on your papers
Max Perutz was Francis Crick's PhD
supervisor and it's not Perutz Watson
and Crick and it was never expected that
it would be and I think that people you
know in science the reward for working
so hard is recognition and I think that
it's great to work with young people but
I think today we're not giving them
anything like the opportunities that we
had when we were that age and I think
it's a problem here I just wanted to add
about your question about collaboration
versus actually being alone I think the
latter is also important I noticed with
myself that some of the times when I'm
most creative is when I'm sitting on an
airplane in a plane and one without
Wi-Fi I'm just sitting there for eight
hours doing nothing and then things pop
up randomly and I get the idea for a new
experiment that I would never got at
home because there's so much going
all the time I think these moments of
just sitting there having nothing to do
it's so important and it's so easy to
lose in the times when especially people
like weed unlike all the time to do
things and that's one aspect of
information technology really hinders
creativity because you just don't get
those times of not being accessible not
being interrupted let me talk to
yourself perhaps elevated co2 levels
that touches on something that member of
the audience Jefferson has asked which
is speaking about creativity
how much did creativity contribute to
your own success in being becoming a
Nobel laureate was it all creativity was
it a lot of hard work as well I don't
know who wants to answer that would you
like to yeah I would say that creativity
is important a lot of luck and you know
one ends up being where one is because
of other people's decisions that you
didn't even understand at the time hard
work is also very important I think
you'll notice that almost all successful
scientists have a lot of stamina and you
know that kind of energy to just keep on
going is really important but I think
you know creativity in some ways is the
drug that drives us I mean when you have
an idea that it's it's a high that you
know I could buy and I would it's just
amazing and you know and it doesn't have
to be a big it's not like oh I just
solved how the universe works it could
just be Oh I suddenly realized while my
experiments being I'm going wrong for
two weeks it's it's an amazing feeling
and and it doesn't actually come you
know I'm I've often thought a will is
creative to come from and you don't sit
down with a list and say in the morning
potential good ideas for today no it's
usually when you're doing something
different you know you're out for a walk
you with the dog in an aeroplane I guess
it doesn't work for me having a shower
something that kind of you know so I
think the worst inventions gonna be a
waterproof ice phone
so I'll just put in a counter to that
Amin for me that the things that I've
you know got most successful was man
picks on the area that seemed like it
was gonna be in potentially important
and I spent years plugging away at it
and and at some point there was some big
challenge and I just you know thought oh
well this is the way to tackle it I
don't
I wonder why nobody else is working on
it this way so I never got these great
inspirations for me it was always I
wonder why nobody else thought to do it
this way you know but there was a whole
lot of work to send that up yeah wish I
got these things I could get excited
than the shower rebellion so we've just
got a minute left ins I guess you have
forgive me for asking this question but
it's sort of I think probably have to
ask it at this meeting can you foresee a
day when you're sitting here and others
are sitting here in your place and one
of you is a machine will there be a
machine that can be awarded a Nobel
Prize don't go for it so so I I would
say nope because I go back to the
original I claim I made as creativity of
looking at things in some basically
different way than people have before
machines are taught how to look at
things it's it's built into them and so
there's sort of it's gonna be a vastly
different machine than anything we're
thinking of now where we build in rules
cuz you follow those rules it's not
gonna be creative like yeah I have no
problem thinking about that I think it
would also be you know great for
publicity be real machine not anyone
else want to try that one oh well I
don't never say never but I don't think
in my lifetime that I'll see a machine
up here answering that question just I
watched you know Watson play jeopardy
and marveled at the ability that
computer
all rare information but putting
unexpected things together in the way
that generates the creative idea I think
is that for the time being not not
something that I'm going to see in a
machine thank you very much
anyone I think maybe when the unexpected
happens then we will notice the
difference I think a machine can be
taught to do the most incredible things
including being creative in a way if you
prescribe the rules for creativity which
we have talked about today so we can
make a machine actually be creative
within certain limits but then something
happens that is not in the rules and
then we'll see the difference right I
just want to say what is so fantastic by
being a scientist it's all the passion
by seeing things that we haven't seen
before
and at the Machine count that's a nice
place to endless have a round of
applause for human passion and creative
so thank you all and that unfortunately
is it for the day we're out of time so I
just like to thank you all for being
here for what's been a really splendid
day we've enjoyed it tremendously and we
look forward to seeing you again on the
9th of December in Stockholm next year